[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
Fourier series and how you can
approximate arbitrary periodic
continuous functions with sum of sines
and cosines of increasingly high
frequency okay so in this short video
lecture we're going to code this up in
Python and we're going to use this
example of this triangular hat function
we're going to approximate this
triangular hat function using a Fourier
series in Python okay and just to remind
you you can download all of these codes
at databook UW comm both in MATLAB and
in Python and we now have all of these
codes on github as well
okay this code all of the Python codes
were modified from MATLAB over to Python
by Daniel Daluz key also okay so I
thought what I would do to start is I
would just remind you what the Fourier
series is so you can take your arbitrary
function this this function is periodic
on a domain minus PI to PI so you take
your periodic function and we're going
to approximate this periodic function by
an infinite sum of cosines of higher
frequencies and sines of higher
frequencies so a K cosine of K times
some frequency be K times sine of K
times some frequency and as K increases
from 0 to 1/2 to higher and higher and
higher
these cosine and sine waves become
higher and higher and higher frequencies
and when you add up all infinitely many
of these sines and cosines you perfectly
approximate this periodic continuous
function ok and just to remind you you
get these coefficients these AKB k's by
projecting or taking the inner product
of your function this function here with
these cosine and sine waves here so the
cave mode is the sorry the K the
coefficient a K is the inner product of
your function f with the K cosine and
similarly for BK ok and so now we're
gonna we're gonna walk through this code
in Python and just kind of see how this
looks when you when you actually work
work through this ok so the first thing
that this code does is defines this
domain from minus PI to PI with a
certain Delta X 0.001 so it's a really
fine Delta X
and then we define this hat function and
the way I define this hat function is I
take my domain and I chop it up into
quarters and the first and last quarter
the function is zero and the middle
second and middle third quarter we have
a positive and a negative slope that
meet in the middle to make this hat
function okay so that's one way to do it
I'm sure there's other ways of building
this hat function but the really
interesting part of the code is here
where we actually compute the Fourier
series okay so here what we're going to
do is we're going to add up from k
equals zero to 20 and I think this is
really the important part here is that
we're not ever actually going to add up
all infinitely many sines and cosines
what we're really gonna do is we're
gonna truncate this at some smaller
value R where R might be 10 or 20 or 50
or something like that so this is a lot
like what we did in the singular value
decomposition we're going to approximate
our function f with a finite number of
modes of these sine and cosine modes
okay and that's what we're gonna walk
through here we're gonna go from K
equals 1 to 2 to 3 all the way up to 20
and see how this approximation gets
better and better the more terms you add
in this in a series okay good and so the
way that we're going to do this is
essentially here this a naught is just
our zeroth mode for cosine of 0 and if
you remember cosine of 0 is just a
constant function equal to 1 okay when K
equals equals 0 so that's basically what
is the the average of this function how
oft set should I should I make this and
then in this for K equals 1 to 20 we're
going to take compute the a K and B K
coefficients by by computing these inner
products here and then we were doing
this I mean this is actually exactly
analogous to the integral form of the
inner product that we're used to seeing
except this is how you would compute it
on data vectors so we had to find this
this function f on a discrete set of
values X so this is a vector F and now
we're gonna build vectors cosine and
sine and we're going to compute the
inner products of these by computing the
dot products
those vectors and we have to normalize
by by the Delta X that we're using okay
so now we compute a K and B K and for a
given number of modes we just add up all
of those sines and cosines in that
proper proportion and then we'll plot
what the what the output is okay and
that's what you see here so in the
background kind of in white you can see
the the hat function and then you can
see as you increasingly add higher and
higher order you get better and better
approximations so the first order
approximation is this kind of orange
orange sinusoidal function here and then
very rapidly as you increase the order
you get closer and closer and closer to
approximating this sharp peak and also
these oscillations on the bottom gets
smaller and smaller and smaller so this
is actually doing a really nice job of
approximating this function even with
only 20/20 sines and cosines okay and of
course you can reason through if you
have an odd function or an even function
whether or not some of these
coefficients will be 0 and others will
not be 0 and so for example this even
function you're just gonna have cosines
and so all the B's should be 0 something
like that ok
and then something else you can do and I
think this is pretty nice is that you
can actually plot all of these
amplitudes so you can plot all of these
a k's or b ches here I think here I'm
only plotting my A's because my B's are
0 since this is a an even function so
what we're gonna do is for the first 100
modes a K from K equals one to a hundred
we're gonna plot the amplitude of the
cosine note the cosine terms and we're
gonna plot what is the reconstruction
error for that number of modes okay so
that's what we have here and so what we
have here the x-axis is number of modes
from zero to a hundred so you want to
increase the number of modes in our
example I think we kept 20 and then what
you have in the y-axis this is the
amplitude of a kay and on the second
plot this is the reconstruction error if
I only kept
the first 10 20 30 40 and so on and so
forth
modes in my expansion and this behaves
exactly how you want it to behave so
this function this error function this
reconstruction error on the bottom is
monotonically decreasing as I increase
my number of modes and this is really
nice so if I have 19 modes and I can add
one more my approximation always gets a
little bit better if I add a 21st mode
it'll get a little bit better so this
error never starts to increase if I add
more modes this is monotonically
decreasing and this is exactly what you
want out of an asymptotic approximation
you want this thing to get better and
better and better the more and more
terms you you include in this series
okay now I think this is also kind of
interesting notice that these Fourier
coefficients have this weird kind of
oscillatory behavior where they're
relatively large and then every fourth
mode they go almost to zero this is ten
to the minus fourteen and I think that
that must be because of some kind of
symmetry and the function I chose so
that these cosines every fourth cosine
coefficient is zero okay I think that
must be something to do with the the
symmetry I chose of this particular
function okay but the real message here
is that as you increasing as you
increase the number of modes in this
expansion you only do better and better
and you actually do pretty a pretty good
job of approximating this function even
with as few as 20 modes okay so you
don't actually have to take the infinite
approximation okay good so in a few
lectures we'll talk about what could go
wrong and then we'll talk about the
discrete Fourier transform and how you
can compute these things really really
rapidly okay thank you